usually car salesmen are thought to be
the slimiest and most manipulative
people in the world aside from using
pushy sales tactics and predatory
financing car salesmen often don't mind
selling you a piece of trash in fact
they'll probably do it with a smile
considering this i don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that 87 of american
adults dislike something about the car
buying process also if you're one of the
few people who had a positive experience
many would argue that you got taken
advantage of so much that you didn't
even realize but one guy named bob
brockman actually took advantage of car
dealerships so hard that they didn't
even realize throughout his career bob
sold overpriced software and hardware to
dealerships across the nation often with
multi-decade-long contracts and after he
was done milking the dealerships bob
turned around and tried to milk the
government but this didn't work out too
well as he was charged with the largest
tax evasion charge in history so here's
how bob brockman made billions by taking
advantage of dealerships and the
government and how he eventually got
caught
taking a look back bob brockman was born
in 1941 in saint petersburg florida this
was just before the us joined world war
ii so bob was born at the height of the
war but this wasn't too bad for bob as
the war would come to an end by the time
he turned five anyway his dad owned a
gas station and his mom worked as a
physiotherapist so he had a pretty
comfortable life financially this
allowed him to focus on his education
and excel in school in fact he graduated
samakumlade which is the highest
distinction from the university of
florida with a business degree in 1963.
bob was also a member of the
university's business honor society so
there's no doubt that he was a pretty
sharp guy out of college bob got a
marketing job at ford while also serving
in the us marine reserves this didn't
last long though as bob switched over to
ibm in 1966 and this is where he really
got his foundation for selling bob was
tasked with the job of selling ibm's
mainframe computer services to car
dealers and out of the gate bob was a
star performer maybe it was his young
ambition or his time at ford we'll
probably never know but it seemed like
bob was born to sell being the star that
he was bob knew that he didn't really
need ibm so in 1970 he left the company
and launched his own company called
universal computer services during his
time at ibm bob had dealt with dozens of
car dealerships and he knew exactly what
they wanted less paperwork so he taught
himself how to code and developed a
piece of software that could synthesize
multiple financial statements into one
for people who owned multiple car
dealerships this was a godsend soon
enough bob expanded his software to help
dealers with managing inventory
generating weekly reports and tracking
sales and the car dealerships ate this
up bob leaned into this business over
the next 20 years and he got quite rich
as he made hundreds of millions up until
this point bob hadn't really done
anything slimy per se sure he might have
used some shady sales tactics when
selling to dealerships but for the most
part bob was simply offering an
extremely valuable service to dealers
and he was rewarded quite handsomely his
next business move however wasn't nearly
as moral
in the early 1990s ford decided that
they were done with the i.t world so
they started looking for buyers for
their id division given that this was
right up bob's alley he made an offer
for 103 million dollars but he had one
condition he wanted the rights to use
ford's logos and branding for five years
now this was a pretty odd request but
bob was already running a respectable
software business and ford probably
thought that bob simply wanted some time
to rebrand the company so they agreed to
the deal but this turned out to be a big
mistake you see bob leveraged the trust
and respect dealers had for ford in
order to take an extremely predatory
deals he charged ludicrous amounts for
everyday tech this included charges such
as a twelve thousand dollar fee to
install a 500 megabyte hard drive and
2400 for a printer you would think that
dealers would have caught on to these
ridiculous fees but many of them didn't
look into the fine print and simply
trusted ford because the fine print was
a 12-inch thick contract when bob's
five-year license for ford's branding
was up though many of these dealers were
in for a rude awakening some of them
tried to rebel against bob alleging that
he had misled them but bob was well
prepared for this any complaint from the
dealers was already accounted for in the
fine print and the dealers couldn't just
wait it out given that these contracts
often extended decades so many of them
tried to go the litigation route by
suing bob but this just drowned them in
legal fees which were often just as bad
as bob's fees at the time it wasn't
really clear how bad these dealerships
were getting screwed dealers that
weren't affected simply dismissed the
concerns as they should have read the
fine print it wasn't until 10 to 15
years later that bob's damages finally
came to light as these dealerships began
to file for bankruptcy and shut down due
to his fees in 2010 for example a
californian entrepreneur named j jill
decided to expand his empire by
purchasing a group of 10 car dealerships
but when he looked into the financials
of the group he realized that the
company owed bob at 3 million and that
they were supposed to pay him at 35 000
every single month after seeing this jay
said quote i know unequivocally that i
wouldn't do business with this guy even
if it was free fortunately for jay he
didn't have to deal with bob for that
long as he agreed to settle for half
that amount but with fees like that it's
no wonder why car salesmen are so pushy
if they don't rip you off they can't
afford to get ripped off themselves
as you would guess the entire fiasco
with ford wasn't the best for ucs's
public reputation so bob started looking
to rebrand himself in the 2000s and the
perfect opportunity came in 2006 when he
got the opportunity to sell his company
to reynolds and reynolds similar to ucs
reynolds and reynolds had been selling
software to auto dealers since the 1980s
they had mostly grown their software
empire through a bunch of acquisitions
and offering to buy ucs was just another
one of their routine acquisitions i
don't think they did much due diligence
as a simple glance at bob's history
would have probably put them off
nevertheless reynolds and reynolds went
ahead and purchased ucs for 2.8 billion
dollars and as you would guess in
brockman fashion there was one critical
contingency for the acquisition bob
stipulated that he must be made ceo of
the merged company for the acquisition
to be completed reynolds agreed and it
didn't take long for bob to start
ruining their reputation as well first
of all he went ahead and implemented
some smaller rules that were annoying
but not too bad he refused to hire
smokers and forced all employees to get
an annual physical to maintain health
insurance some of his other policies
however were much more damaging about
one third of round's revenue was from
general motors to their integrated
dealership management program
considering how integral gm was to the
business you would think that bob would
treat them very well but in 2007 gm
ended up filing a lawsuit against
reynolds accusing them of refusing to
make requested changes to the software
reynolds ended up settling with gm a
year later which ended the gm
partnership somehow reynolds had already
lost their biggest customer just two
years after bob took over but bob didn't
care as he had his eye on a much bigger
price in 2007 a company called coindata
came out with a product called docupad
docupad is basically a large tabletop
tablet that eliminates a need for
paperwork when selling a car this makes
it much easier for car salesmen to
upsell customers on insurance programs
and amenities that they simply don't
need despite the appealing product most
car dealerships avoided the system given
that it was extremely expensive coin
data charged ten thousand dollars to set
up each system and then an additional 1
000 every month as a maintenance fee and
if a dealership wanted to modify
anything they were charged an extra 297
dollars for each modification coindata
had a tough time getting dealerships to
pick up these tabs but bob wasn't
worried about that in 2009 he offered to
form an exclusive marketing partnership
with coin data and over the next two
years they revamped the system in 2011
the duo came out with a new docupad and
with bob at the wheel these sold like
hotcakes it's still not clear if these
systems are actually worth it for
dealerships but there was no question
that they were worth it for bob
by this point bob was raking in billions
and though his business could be labeled
as immoral or unethical it definitely
wasn't illegal it would have been in
bob's best interest to keep it this way
but unfortunately it didn't take long
for greed to get to him in the late
1990s an investment banker from goldman
sachs named robert f smith reached out
to bob originally he offered to buy out
ucs from bob but bob turned the script
on robert bob offered to help robert
start up a new investment bank called
visa equity partners with 1 billion
dollars but in return bob wanted robert
to help him set up a foreign trust that
did not report to the irs technically
there were legal ways to accomplish this
and legitimate reasons to do so but i
think it was pretty clear that bob was
going to use this for illegal purposes
nonetheless this was an opportunity of a
lifetime for robert so he took up bob on
the offer the department of justice has
since labeled this deal as evidence of
conspiracy and scheme and artifice to
defraud so here's how the fraud worked
bob owned a charitable trust called
eugene brockman that was based in
bermuda this charitable trust on the
holding company called spanish steps
holding registered in nevis and spanish
steps holdings on the company called the
point investment which was registered in
the british virgin islands and the point
investments was investing in vista's
foreign fund bob used this convoluted
string of companies to funnel money
offshore and avoid taxes bob and robert
got away with this for decades but
eventually the irs caught on robert
didn't resist the irs much and quickly
turned on bob when he took in the
investment from bob he knew that this
could eventually happen and he was
prepared for it robert worked with the
irs to give them all the information
they needed and he happily paid a 139
million fine for his involvement in the
scheme from his perspective the deal
with bob was well worth it vista equity
partners had grown to 86 billion dollars
in assets under management which made
robert worth 8.9 billion dollars
considering this a 139 million fee
wasn't that bad as for bob his lawyers
tried to argue that he was suffering
from dementia and that he couldn't serve
jail time but quartz dismissed this
argument in november we don't know what
the final sentence is going to be but
it's probably not going to be that
forgiving at this point though it
doesn't really matter that much bob is
already 80 years old so he's already
avoided paying for his crimes for most
of his life aside from this the latest
account suggests that bob is worth 4.7
billion dollars so even if he was
charged a multi-hundred million dollar
fine or even a billion dollar fine it
wouldn't actually hurt him that much
financially really the worst punishment
he could get at this point is being
forced levi's last days in jail and that
might very well end up happening but
we'll just have to wait and see what do
you guys think should be bob's
punishment comment that down below also
drop a like if you're glad that bob gave
car dealers a taste of their own
medicine and of course consider checking
out our international channels to watch
our videos in other languages and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one